well in a long and rambling response
former president Donald Trump reacted to
the January 6 committee after it voted
unanimously to issue him a subpoena
committee chairman Benny Thompson is
expected to officially issue The
subpoena in a matter of days but it may
be more symbolic than substantive time
is running out for the panel to wrap up
its investigation before this
Congressional term ends Caitlyn Huey
Burns is at the White House with more on
the story Caitlyn good morning good
morning Michelle well by voting to issue
that subpoena the Committee Member said
they want to hear from the man at the
center of their investigation but in a
14-page letter former president Trump
wouldn't say whether he'll comply
instead he went on about reiterating his
false claims about the 2020 election
we must seek the testimony under oath of
January 6th Central player that Central
player won't say whether he'll comply
with a subpoena from the committee
investigating the attack on the capitol
former president Trump wrote a 14-page
letter to Chairman Benny Thompson
slamming the committee members as Thugs
and listing a ream of disproven claims
of election fraud he also included
photos to draw attention to the size of
the crowd at the January 6th rally this
as new video shows how speaker Nancy
Pelosi being told Trump was planning to
come to the Capitol that day
they're waiting for this for trespassing
on the capital ground I want to punch
him out and I'm going to go to jail I'm
going to be happy the video shot by her
filmmaker daughter also shows Pelosi
speaking with vice president Mike Pence
don't let anybody know where you are
Committee Member Zola Lofgren says she
thinks the panel proved that Trump never
intended to obey the election results
and directed a mob to storm the Capitals
I think he needs to explain himself to
the American people we're going to give
him a chance to do that Former Republic
King Congressman Denver riggleman who
once advised the committee fears the
timing of the subpoena might animate the
GOP ahead of the midterms what is the
effect of that practically speaking
so you know I think it's entirely
appropriate uh you know to subpoena the
president or task for an interview but I
think it's the right thing at the wrong
time
now the committee has until the end of
the year to finish their work which
means they're they have little time to
get the former president to comply with
the subpoena and remember if House
Republicans win back the house in next
month's election they could withdraw The
subpoena next year Jeff Caitlin thank
you very much